thank you
[Music]
welcome back to another strange episode
of careful boys today we have with us
Walter Hong hey
I would also have Ken Nick Colleen
myself no more Joe or Anthony yeah sadly
where's Anthony he's not feeling well so
hopefully um he uh he makes it through
because he's sick yeah yeah send your
wishes to Anthony wish him a good
recovery yeah today's episode is gonna
be all about Texas what do we know about
Texas what do we think about Texas
what's your favorite Texas city it's big
you lived in Houston for well nope San
Antonio no uh Austin yes yeah
that's not wealthy City it was pretty
cool I I like visiting Austin yeah I do
know Joe Rogan not personally were you
out there during the time he was no I
was there in 2019 yeah what do you think
of the owner of Whole Foods lives in
Austin oh really yeah uh what who else
is out there Dell the person like Dell
yeah the big you know anyway uh I was
there for only like three months and uh
I actually didn't live in downtown
Austin which is actually my favorite
area because there's a lot more things
going on but when you live out in like
the suburbs it sucks dude oh it does
yeah it sucks because you have to drive
like 20 minutes just to get to a grocery
store or like anywhere because you're
just Suburban grocery stores no so it
there is but you have to drive like far
oh like to get there like I can't just
walk there you know because you're just
yeah or take a horse yeah because people
ride horses like casually out there just
uh not where I was no uh straight up
like neighborhood if you go to the next
thing neighborhood
I'm not even kidding I probably was
actually how did that make you feel
there
um it was whatever I'm not I'm not like
a stranger to that because when I grew
up I was like pretty much the only Asian
around like a bunch of non-asians yeah
but
um yeah that's the main thing it's just
so much space which is it could be nice
depending on how you uh for the horses
yeah what are some of the uh what are
some of the things that that Texas has
over Cali in your opinion
um space okay
um
everything's cheaper there
um but now I heard it's like kind of
like getting up there in price in terms
of like food whatever uh no because they
keep going over there it could be I
don't know I don't know honestly the
economics of it but um yeah it's like
similarly priced gas is cheaper
um what else
um the food kind is like all right
I do like Tex-Mex actually that was like
one of my favorite things because that's
what was different about their versus
here because we don't have Tex-Mex here
we have like Applebee's does Apple
babies yeah but it's not good let's stop
being around the bush yeah tell us tell
us a thing we really want to know what
do you want to not
the guys
yeah tell us we gotta know I wanna know
I do want to know Colleen want to know
that's a tough one man I don't know are
you uh are you into tall dudes I don't
know I like how you says are you what
kind of question is that dude like Rich
guys because everybody there is like you
like model guys because
no because you're not in Texas
everything's bigger so like people there
are bigger things bigger even even like
because there's Asian girl dogs are
bigger than girls yeah
a little more petite but over there they
eat good so they're like they're bigger
yeah but not like you know
it's it's whatever not like what okay
yeah yeah like what they're like
but yeah like when you say bigger like
are you saying like fatter or like just
thicker they just look like like healthy
yeah
it's bigger
I think it's because the portions there
are so big even oh yeah so I tried fun
Austin yeah it's it's not as good you're
telling me it's not as good as sgv
oh dude SUV actually SUV's okay too
who's making it it's Vietnamese people
oh it is actually it's actual Vietnamese
people because there's a lot of oh yeah
that's another thing there's a lot of
Vietnamese people in Texas for some
reason oh I'm sure is that a pro or con
for you huh sorry to hear that so it's
neutral it's not a problem it's a matter
of fact I think it's cool my condolences
they're just there other videos where
you mad when you got off the plane and
just saw more Vietnamese people no he
was like I was trying to get away from
this yeah
so did the plane make it yeah
disappointed
baby did you follow any of the sports
teams out there like the Texans the
Cowboys so fun fact I went to my first
tailgate in when I moved to Austin for
like college sports yeah it was for uh
what is it UT yeah yeah it was huge
University of Texas it was huge you
could hear the crowd from like miles
away from the stadium and uh there was
like uh bands playing there was like a
lot of things going on but I asked my
friend what is the tailgate and he said
oh you'll see and I'm like okay so I
show up there
literally every tent everybody's setup
is music drinks and barely any food it's
like mostly drinks so no food so no big
portions of the tailgates no is that
something that tailgating like so Essie
if you ever go to a USC tailgate
um basically like 90 000 people watch
the game they go to Coliseum prior to
that there's also an additional 30 000
that just show up the tailgate and
they'll have like satellite TV or
whatever and they'll just set up a TV
they'll like barbecues like beers you
know like margaritas and all that it's a
whole thing and when you go to
somebody's uh college campuses that have
nothing around there but the college
campus then it becomes a huge like
Affair like all day yeah yeah yeah yeah
all day just drunk the whole day yeah
and I was like wow this is pretty
interesting definitely not something I
would go to again because it's not
really my thing I don't watch football I
don't drink that much would you would
you give Texas Another Chance by trying
another city maybe going to Dallas or no
because no no I would not because
I've been to Texas quite a bit
um because I have friends that live in
Dallas and I actually stayed in Dallas
for like a few weeks just because and
I've also been in the small cities next
to Dallas because I stayed in the city
and outside of the city in Dallas and in
Austin and then I've also been to
Houston so it's kind of like very
similar but obviously it's all different
but like the vibe is kind of similar
this it's just so much emptiness so it's
very good when you were there no I did
not maybe you're not you didn't fulfill
the whole Texas experience
I think I had uh Black's Barbecue I had
do you like blacks Everyone likes blacks
yeah it was good yeah
[Laughter]
oh ribeye they did have that yeah added
blacks uh no okay
how would you rate the average Texan
like person you mean to person
interaction man they're cool they're
super nice nicer than people here right
I mean you could find [__] there you
can find [__] I don't think stop
being so neutral bro what is it is
what's your favorite
it is vanilla sometimes
sometimes it's Rocky Road come on
do you agree do you agree generally
generally with their politics like as a
whole Texas you know they're like dude
you want a neutral answer a little bit
different than Cali you know huh a
little bit but I didn't really talk to
people about politics when I was there
um oh you speak Vietnamese let me turns
away
you know what was interesting
I actually got to know the dance
community in Austin and they were super
cool it was very are they creative in
Austin for dance because it's such a
creative City and they're super creative
a little more creative than here
sometimes
because I feel like you went too far too
far someone's mad now yeah we didn't
want him
but I feel like La dancers sometimes
take being in La for granted because we
have so many good dancers oh yeah so
they don't try as hard right because
they just start copying each other yeah
and then in Austin they really really
want to be like oh dude I'm going to
make this new thing and whatever it kind
of reminds me of how when uh I started
back in the day because that's how we
were when we were younger but then for
them it's like ongoing they're always
trying to innovate and whatever I'm like
dude there's actually really good
dancers you know yeah but they you just
don't hear about it as much unless you
were in the community right I think a
lot of people don't realize that in in
the breaking Community Texas played on a
massive role in the early 2000s they
were game changers of the whole like
form and style yeah breaking tons of
creative people came out of there and a
lot of them were never seen again after
that era yeah half my original b-boy
crew from like 1999 half of them broke
off and moved to Texas and they ended up
in in This Crew called United b-boys
which is like a massive uh Texan crew
spanning like three different cities and
those guys are total game changers they
made up so much stuff that people in
other countries are doing and don't know
it started in like San Antonio yeah yeah
that's oh yeah San Antonio I've never
been to San Antonio but I always heard
like the dancing there was pretty huge
they have a large uh arena for the San
Antonio Spurs it's like 30 or 40 000
which is for basketball readers that's
huge so they actually have a curtain
that blocks off the extra seats oh yeah
but throw that out there about San
Antonio well what's your favorite uh
sports team in Texas my favorite sports
team in Texas
um
you know what I I don't um go to games
but I have been to a Dallas Mavericks
game because of uh Dancing Yeah Yeah
they brought us for the show what year
and it was like 20 20. it was like right
after you see Luca huh you see Luca I
don't even know who that is yes I did
actually I did I did like NADA did you
see Mark Cuban the owner I know I I
didn't know who was who honestly but I
was just like wow this is Dallas
Mavericks Texas seems like it's popping
off dude I like Texas a lot oh my god
I've only been to San Antonio for a
fight that I had a corner but everyone
like speaking of Austin everyone seems
like
me and my wife we watch a show called
kill Tony oh yeah and uh their comedy
scene over there seems really cool yeah
so we're like oh that that can that
would be tight yeah that would be tight
to just go see your show over there yeah
and then a lot of Jiu Jitsu guys are
like there's a huge like Fitness
Community out in uh Austin that's like
blown up and you know what's dope about
Austin was uh South by Southwest that
was so fun that was my first time going
to Austin and it's this huge festival
with like music almost they block out
the whole like downtown area and each
bar that's a venue or a theater it's a
part of it so you can have a badge and
you can walk to this bar and there's
already a set playing and then you can
go across the street and there's another
one and it's all a part of that music
festival and on top of that they have a
film festival and a gaming Festival all
happening in like the span of like two
weeks it was insane a guy who doesn't
drink you go to a lot of bars huh where
a guy doesn't drink you go to a lot of
them I do because I like to socialize
yeah no I don't I drink not like oh yeah
I want to get wasted you know yeah I
like that about you yeah thanks you
should try again
I was back in the I was a champion what
about now now no no like I can't drink
too much I will happen
stop being spicy bro
wait hold up hold up sure yes there was
actually like a like uh my first time in
Dallas was I think uh the people that
brought that brought me out were like
the Vietnamese Community out there and
they're all nice there's a dope ass
Vietnamese like VSA
I think they were like mostly Club
promoters and stuff oh nice yeah even
cooler yeah why do you hate your old
people yeah who said I hate them dude
the way the vibe yeah the insinuation
emanate the animated I don't think he's
giving off my vibe at all have you been
in Texas
yeah you guys are very group thank you
you want to move there you said no I
think it's like uh I wanna if I had to
move in anywhere right now I'd probably
be that's a contender yeah it's a
contender for sure all right what city
would you go to I don't know pick one
now why and why Corpus Christi yeah
why not you guys like Corpus Christi
fans never been yeah I got called the
[__] in San Antonio
did you tell them oh yeah dude
like racism
in Atlanta more than Texas really no
Texas was cool man nobody was dude it
was opposite in Texas for me when I when
the first time I went like I thought you
were Mexican yeah that's exactly what I
was thinking we performed at like a club
in Dallas that was like it was like
mostly like Asians and white people and
like it was like they were just way
cooler than Asians and white people in a
club out here yeah like everybody was
way more social like hello is not like
an awkward thing in Most states besides
here that's true like here everyone's
apprehensive and they're like I don't
want to bother you or I don't want to
look stupid
because it's like that in New York don't
they say that like people yeah walking
by each other they gotta get [__] done
like everyone's rushing dude imagine you
said hi to everyone in New York though
but even like even like the like the
staff of the club was like friendly
which is cool normally like here it's
like you know like staff of places yeah
yeah they feel you feel like they're
talking because they have to yeah but
then there they were just like I still
talk to them today like yeah all the
people that I met in Texas in 2009 are
still friends of mine today and it's
weird it's like not normal right yeah I
think everyone outside of like the
corner States yeah yeah right yeah like
the Metropolitan like areas like
everyone's like I don't even think they
they think they're nice they're just
yeah yeah that's just them you know
whereas like out here I think we're
[__] up yeah like they're normal like
because like you're talking about high
like so uh when I used to run uh
children everyone that passed I would
say hi I would just be like hey hi and
like I'd say about 30 40 will say hi
back yeah some people get mad yeah it's
like some people go like yeah
that's what it is guys you're one of
those people no I don't get mad I always
say hi
I'm trying to be quirky with it
it is it feels it feels like you're
intrusive or you just go
[Music]
see there's certain people you know that
you have to go two and there's some
people that you're like hey what's up
you could feel it you know yeah
it's one thing like just like not say hi
back but it's when they try to they make
you feel stupid for saying hi yeah
that's that's what they go the extra
mile so like that that's what it's like
that's like why we're known as
unfriendly because we go the extra mile
to make you feel stupid for saying hi to
me yeah right and I think that's where
like except it sets us apart from other
states
this is a funny story she was driving to
uh her job on the west side of town west
side of L.A which is very like how would
you describe the west side of L.A it's
in the west yeah but like
characteristics oh they're the they're
the interracial couple they're one of
the interracial couple capitals really
really yeah you see a lot
yeah yeah yeah still interesting which
is different yeah
I guess stereotypes
because it takes forever it takes
forever and then sometimes people can be
you know head up their own butts
sometimes the drivers suck yeah
definitely but she was driving through
the residential yeah and my wife saw a
coyote on the street right and there's a
lot of you know coyotes in the area it's
like in the hills and [__]
and then a couple blocks down she saw a
lady walking her like two dogs and my
wife rolls down the window and she goes
there's a coyote down the street I just
want to let you know the lady looks at
Tiff and goes why the [__] should I care
that's so [__] up that's so funny but
it's so funny but it's so [__] keep
going I hope your dogs get eaten yeah
yeah she should have but she just was
like Tiff was like oh it drives away
right but like that I don't know if you
get the same reaction if you were in
Texas
[Laughter]
and those areas are like there's a nice
those are nice houses like you gotta
have a nice chunk of change to live up
there you know and then yeah yeah so
then for her to respond that way just
like so agree she could have been like
okay like that's yeah that's reasonable
to go out of your way and make a
sentence why the [__]
I feel like a Texas response would have
been hey is it better for my dogs being
eaten by a coyote or you oh yeah oh dude
is that too much sorry oh God Texas
viewers are gonna be upset I'm gonna be
enraged
yeah anybody have anything bad to say
about Texas
I didn't tell you I wish it wasn't so
far yeah I would love it I wish it was a
drivable state
drive over there I wish not everyone was
allowed to carry guns oh why
like you know if someone's like mentally
unstable
I don't know we can ask the other 49
states
but that's been going so well for us so
yeah well you know there was there was a
shooting this morning where uh in
downtown L.A right at a apartment thing
okay great I gotta check off in a white
SUV four people in critical conditions
why SUV I always find that strange that
like when um when when shootings like
that happened in La let's say like five
dudes got shot it doesn't get classified
as a mass shootie which is weird because
I think National is supposed to be four
or more really yeah but like it's like
let's say that three guys got shot on
this side and two guys got shot from
that side do they not count that as like
does it have to be one guy shooting a
whole size is it declared
a gaggle
I applaud you for using couple in few
properly yeah oh thank you so much you
have very little faith in me oh I did
not but you know I'll tell you right now
Walter English I'm not gonna use a
product
and I say when I say a couple I mean
like 50. yeah yeah you know you know
what might be a good City Amarillo my
favorite Amarillo
yeah oh I think that might be a cool
place because I don't want to go there
so bad as a kid because they have a
freaking um I don't know if they still
have it but they had this one restaurant
where like if you can eat the whole like
porterhouse steak it's like a giant I
would love it it's like I forgot how
many ounces it is
like three or four pounds yeah I want to
go to Texas
I want to experience the barbecue yeah a
little bit more you know what I think is
incorrect there's a place in Austin
right yeah yeah I'd say they're
Franklin's or something there's a couple
the one by South by Southwest the one
that's in that area yeah weighs like six
hours yeah I think that's Franklin yeah
Franklin's and that's the one where
Obama ate at or something like that so
it's like super popular there what sucks
is when you win that then I ain't going
in there yeah they don't tell you like
where they might run out
so um my friends went because their
movie was in South by Southwest so like
one of their fans were like we'll wait
in line for you just come down we'll
call you when we're close so they all
came down they ordered a whole bunch of
barbecue the person right behind them
they go we just ran out oh
and so they waited for six hours yeah
like that they should get like a voucher
everywhere they'd be the first person in
line to come right that's like you can't
tell like how much people are gonna
order that's true yeah but yeah they
don't have so much
[Laughter]
you sound like a Texan